[Music]
hi
imagine having partial measurements of a
high dimensional complex dynamical
system say you have a few sensors
submerged in a turbulent flow
or maybe you can track a few particles
in a complex granular material flow
or maybe you have eeg measurements or
fmri measurements of the brain
and you'd like in all these systems to
understand the underlying dynamics the
high dimensional dynamics
this sounds like an almost impossible
task but this is exactly the problem we
tackle in our recent paper discovering
governing equations
with deep delay autoencoders
now this is work i've done with my
colleagues kathleen champion nathan kutz
and stephen brunton
the basic idea is
you have some measurements let's say
one-dimensional measurements y of t
and you can embed these measurements in
a higher dimensional space by time delay
embedding
and we know that this time delay
embedding coordinates
with time series h of t
is diffiomorphic to the original full
state dynamics z of t
we know that because there's a theorem
that says it token's embedding theorem
and we know that we can go from h to z
back and forth using an invertible
function
v and c
some continuous nonlinear continuous
function
now
we also know that given data in the full
state
attractor or coordinates we can learn
the dynamics z
dot equals f of z
now f is an unknown
function it's an analytical unknown
function
phi and c are also unknown functions
and what we're proposing here is to
learn all these functions from data and
the only given data is y of t
of course this is a highly imposed
problem and
here the the art is all about designing
the loss function to optimize for
this and to recover the full state
attractor along with the dynamical
system that underlies it
so how does that work let's say you have
one-dimensional measurements y of t
and here i'm showing these measurements
being shifted in time like shifting a
window
towards positive time
and let's highlight four of these
measurements as we're shifting them in
time y of t y of t plus tau y of t plus
two tau y of t plus t tau so here i'm
taking four but you can take more
what you can do is take these four
points in one dimension
and project them on a higher dimensional
space
as one point in these in this four
dimensional
delay coordinates
so now we have this one one point and
four dimensions that is an embedding of
these four points in one d
now
as i said earlier we know that
the full state attractor from which this
one dimensional measurements came
this is the higher dimensional system
we know that
these this coordinate system is
differentomorphic to this coordinate
system
because of token's embedding theorem
and we also know that given data in the
full state coordinates we can discover
the underlying dynamics using sparse
identification of nonlinear dynamics or
also known as cindy
for example in the example illustrated
here
this is the lorenz system it's a
three-dimensional system with three
unknown parameters
so
now how do we actually develop this
method it seems like there are a lot of
unknowns the theomorphism is unknown the
sparse identification of solution
dynamics is also a machine learning
algorithm with unknown coefficients and
the delay embedding is also there is no
unique way of doing that there's um the
number of dimensions that we choose is
unknown and tau is unknown so for
validation we start with a known
dynamical system high dimensional
dynamic system and we project it on 1d
for example we can take z1 to be
actually y of t and then therefore
closing the loop and developing and
refining each one of these pieces
so that we can at some point discover a
method that works for dynamical systems
that we don't know
so
let's focus on each one of these
parts in this cycle
so
we know that time delay embedding is
possible
it's all a matter of choosing the
dimensions so we can in this case define
the henkel matrix the henkel matrix each
column in the henkel matrix is one data
point in the delay coordinates
so here we have q data points and we can
write this time series in the delay
coordinates as h1 h2 to hq
here i'm showing a continuous attractor
but in reality this will also be
discrete
um
why use time delay embedding this
technique has been used extensively for
example to show to
highlight the difference between chaos
and
noisy dynamics or noise
and recently my colleagues showed that
chaos can be cast as an intermittently
forced linear system using time delay
embedding or using the dominant modes of
the henkel matrix i encourage you to
look at this paper it's very interesting
um
and on the other hand we have the sparse
identification of nonlinear dynamics
method or cindy that
takes
data in
full state coordinates or any coordinate
system and tries to discover the
underlying dynamics f using a
form of sparse regression
so if you don't know about this method i
encourage you to look at this paper but
here i'm going to briefly illustrate how
it works
so you start with a data matrix
where you have time series z1 z2 to zq
and
you define a dictionary the dictionary
will include
z1 z2 z3 z1 times z2 z1 cubed etc all
these possibilities you can also have
sine of z
and derivatives in other
independent
variables like if you have x and you you
can get a pde in fact
um and at the end you cast this problem
as the in the form of this differential
equation where c now is a matrix of
unknown coefficients and what we're
trying to do is optimize for these
unknown coefficients to fit the data so
we're optimizing this loss function
where we minimize the residual
squared of the differential equation and
we also try to minimize the number of
terms in the differential equation
therefore maximizing sparsity
so cindy has been
improved extensively in recent years and
there are of course it's an active area
of research how do you discover the best
differential equation that underlies a
given dynamics in any coordinate system
now the last piece
of this puzzle is this differomorphism
we know that it exists but we don't know
where it is
so how do we go from this side to this
side
we don't know exactly what it looks like
but we know that's very non-linear and
we know that this coordinate system will
probably be much higher than it will
certainly be much higher dimensional
than this coordinate system in fact the
tokens embedding theorem says that this
coordinate system should be
at least um
three uh two times this coordinate the
dimension of this coordinate system plus
one so if this is three this has to be
at least seven
and what better than a neural network to
make that approximation more
specifically a sort of encoder
now we know that a neural network can do
the job because if we know both sides of
this equation we show in the paper that
you can actually do this fitting really
well and it generalizes well
and we also show that you can actually
do this transform using a combination of
svd decomposition and a neural network
so that
you make a linear compression of that
coordinate system and then you make the
rest with a non-linear
transformation using an encoder
so now that we saw all of these puzzles
let's kind of summarize it and highlight
what we're looking for so we have an
unknown system uh here we know the
equations but in reality we don't
um
and we're just making one-dimensional
measurements y of t let's say this is
going to be x1 for example
so we time delay embed
y into h
and then we have an encoder that takes
us from h to z
then we can map z to z dot with this
analytical function f
therefore um discovering a nonlinear
dynamical system and then we should be
also able to go from z back to h
this makes this an
encoder an auto encoder and f is of
course an analytical function so that's
the cindy part so it's a cindy
autoencoder and it uses delay
coordinates so it's a delays in the
autoencoder
now after doing that reconstruction
you have of course to minimize all these
three functions
now to show you
our results for example concerning the
lorenz system we discover something that
looks like the original system of course
this is an impulse problem again and
there are a lot of diphyomorphisms that
are similar to the original lorenz and
what we're assuming here is that the
optimal
solution given a certain loss function
is similar at least has some invariance
that is shared with the original system
and you can notice that the discovered
system here is
even sparser than the original system
and we can look at the system and make
predictions for at least the first
dimension and gain some insight as to
the structure of the attractor
something that we cannot do with one
dimension only
now this work is based on previous work
this is very similar architecture to the
cindy autoencoder developed in this
paper done by my colleagues so please
look at this paper as well before you
dive deeper into this work
um
all right let's dive a little deeper how
do we actually do that because it's all
about defining the loss function what is
the loss function that allows us to go
from one-dimensional measurements to
three-dimensional dynamical equation
system equations
so we have y we delay embed y and h and
we said we can go from h to z uh using
combination of svd and encoder or just
an encoder
and we can do that back to h
thus having an autoencoder
now the cindy part is taking z and
projecting it on a higher dimensional
space by defining this dictionary
potential terms on in our in our
differential equation and then
multiplying it by this unknown function
c that we're also optimizing for to get
z dot
now
we can also go back to
h to constrain our our model even
further um you can see in the original
paper of
delay autoencoders that
it's useful to take the derivative of
the input data
h dot and
by automatic differentiation to get z
dot the details of how you go from here
to here are explained in the paper
now you can do the same thing to go from
z dot to h dot
and you can notice that there are a lot
of redundancies there's z dot z bar dot
an h dot in h bar dot and an h bar and h
so we want all of these to be the same
we don't want the redundancies so this
is what defines our loss functions so
first we minimize the difference between
z dot and z bar dot
and you can derive these as a function
of the input h
and the functions v c and c
um you can also we also want to minimize
the difference between h bar h dot and h
bar dot as well as the reconstruction
loss between h bar and h
now there's one last loss we can also
add to constrain our model even further
which is to take the latent variable z
and to integrate it using the discovered
model
like this so now we have z would be this
latent variable at the given epoch or at
the given training step
is defined as z at t zero and then we
integrate that in time using the cindy
coefficient c and
we get these time steps
or the solution z hat at t 1 until z hat
at t n
and we want the first dimension of this
solution to be also
the input data which means that we would
like our discovered model to have the
first dimension match the input data
that we're giving it this is of course
an assumption but it constrains our
model even further to get something that
makes sense
so let's look at what the algorithm
actually does so here we initialize our
neural network to map to the dominant
modes
in the latent variable
and starting from that approximation we
try to train the algorithm to find the
most optimal solution given those losses
of course there's something i didn't
mention also that we're minimizing the
sparsity of the solution
so here the full system is unknown of
course we're just measuring the x
dimension the first dimension
and the yellow
curve is the latent variable and the red
curve is the integrated cindy model so
you can see that
cindy does a good job learning from the
latent variable but of course with time
as the system is trying to minimize the
sparsity of the solution um
the attractor slowly drifts away from
the original system because it has no
information as to the the the other
dimensions um and
here uh comes the important part about
um
about improving method as you can see
the model that's discovered here is
different from the model that i showed
you before and this is to highlight the
fact that the solution is not going to
be unique depending on how you weigh
your losses which losses you include and
for example the architecture of the
neural network the dimension of the
embedding there are so many hyper
parameters
but given a system if you know for
example that the energy is conserved you
can bake in those symmetries um physical
physics informed symmetries in the loss
function and therefore improve that
discovery and get it closer and closer
to the original system i think this
method is a good start to start from
somewhere to say that the origin system
has this kind of structure has these
kind of
terms in the differential equation and
as we try to improve our data-driven
modeling methods we find
more and more refined models that are
high dimensional from our measurements
but
have a structure that describes the
physics
so we tried also we also tried this on
the lorenz water wheel so we took this
video from youtube and
from the harvard natural sciences
lecture demonstrations
and
we took that video and we wanted to
extract one dimensional measurement
which is the angle of this video ideally
you would take the video and pass it to
some kind of
encoder cnn encoder and immediately
extract the latent variable one latent
variable which is the the angle
but in this case we use a machine
learning algorithm to detect the lines
and to cluster the lines and to discover
the angle of those lines and you can see
this is a very noisy kind of measurement
and
when we extract those measurements um
with the angular velocity here
we have noise so we have to kind of
smooth the data
but from that smooth data we use our
algorithm and we discover an attractor
and here we're showing the model
solution using cindy and the latent
variable of course this is kind of a
butterfly shaped uh attractor but
there's a lot of improvements that have
to be that can be done to get closer to
the original system
and this is the discovered analytical
model
so um this is a
i'm very excited about this work to
apply it to problems where we actually
don't know the solution we don't know
the underlying dynamics
and if you have that data i would be
very excited to collaborate with you to
discover the underlying dynamics
of your complex system and if you have
ideas on improving this method i
encourage you to look at the paper and
to give me ideas and to pitch ideas and
and to collaborate because this is
what research is all about so thank you
[Music]
you